فيديو الجوهره الحقيلي المتبرعه للطفله
اهلا وسهلا فيك الجوهره ايضا ينضم الينا
والد الطفله جمانه وجمانه كمان ايضا
الحربي اهلا وسهلا فيكم نشره الرابعه
وخلينا نبدا معك ابو جمانه وايش اللي حصل
مع جمانه وحضريتوها انه
متبرع اسم اضطريتوها تبحث عن متابعين
والله
بعد ثمان شهور صار فيه تغير باللون العيون
فهذا يعني كان سبب عدم الفحص ال- المستمر
صباح الامانه متابعه بعد الولاده بشهر شهر
شهر همم قرر المستشفى الحرس الوطني همم
هذه القصه وهي عمرها ثمانيه شهور تقريبا
شوي صعبه
ليش تاخذ خطوبه هذه
انها تتبرع لطفله او لاحد اسرع ما تعرفه
ثقافه التبرع عندنا شويه معدومه بالنسبه
لي انا يعني الامانه حرام او من الانانيه
انه نحتفظ باعضاء من جسمنا نفسنا بس يعني
زي الكبد زي الكلى ما راح يضرنا اذا
يتبرعنا فيه الكبد يتدخل
الكلى تقدر تعيش فيها بوحده في اجزاء
كثيره بعد ففي ناس كثير او متضررين كثير
او مرضى كثير يعني يتوفون من التعب هذا
انا اشوف انانيه ان احنا نحتفظ بهذا الشيء
نفسنا
الموضوع هذا الشخص اللي يجب انه يتبرع
الذي ثقافه موجوده عندك من زمان وكنت
تفكري فيها قبل انه تصير همم قصه جمانه بس
انه جاء الوقت المناسب اللي انت ما كنتي
تعرفيها اصلا
فعلا انا تقريبا من عمري 15 سنه وانا
جالسه اطلع كثير من ضمن الاطلاع اللي انا
جلسه اقراه والقراءات اللي انا جئت اقراها
كرهت عن الكبد انه في عمر 15 سنه
ينمو الانسان ما راح اصلا يتضرر منه من
فقدان الجزء منه
من وقتها بدا هذا الشيء النجا افكر دايما
الجراءات كيف تمت كان في ثلاثه في موضوع
التمر في اجراءات
يعني
معروف يعني ما احد يقدر يسهل الامان
[موسيقى]
الا الصحه حتى برودك تعطي حد صحتك ما تقدر
طيب همم
انا اللي اعرفه الجوهره انه انت سويتها من
دون اهلك ما يعرفوا لانهم كان معرضين هل
العمليه وكليه للقصه وشلون مو انت طبعا ما
تقدرتي تقنعيهم لكن شلون بلغيهم
م
عطيتهم
لما انا قلت انه انا ارغب اني انا عندي
هذا الفكره الامانه ما لقيت اي قبول في
هذا الموضوع همم
فين يعني انه انا اقدر اقوم بخير انه في
يعني في يقين داخلين وانا بكون شخص يعني
بصحه وعافيته كامله
بسال عن عن اسرتك وعن افراد العائله عندك
يعني هل اعزز هذا الموقف اللي شفته من
الجوهره
ممكن يتبرع على احد
والطفله
يوم من الايام
وباذن الله العمر بيد الله سبحانه وتعالى
تقريبا
اخذت وقت لما انت قلت لهم انا هتبرع لاحد
المستشفى
شهر ونص وخلصنا كل الاجراءات اقدم عليها
كيف عرفت كنت ابحث كثير بس ما بحثت لان
كان في امور عندي بخلصها بحثت في تقريبا
السنه هذه لانه انا احتاج اني انا اتبرع
بجزء منك
فدلوني على ابو جمانه
هي عائله ما قالوا انها هي بنت صغيره
تحتاج الكبد انه واحده من افرادها في فشل
الكبد انه حالتها مره خطا خلاص خلاص ابدا
انا اصلا داخل مستشفى بس بره عندها
الموضوع يعني ما همني
خليني اسال عن ردود فعل الناس الي حولك
لما اعرف انه انت رح تتبرعتي مكان الاهل
ما كانوا يعرفوا وانت كنت بهذا العمل مثل
ما قلت انه في يقين وفي دافع وفي ثقافه
تبرع حسيت انه غيرت شيء من الناس اللي
حوالك
مختلفه تماما حول ثقافه التبرع في نظرتهم
فخر الامانه قبل ما كانت موجوده في هذا
الشيء همم
غيرت او في ناس يسالوني كثير عن التبرع
وكيف نقدم عليه انا شفت انه يعني
مساله النظافه شويه
وصحتها فريق طبي للحرس الوطني
انا بالحد الجنوبي
متواصلين معي مواعيد مواعيد
تحاليلها اي شيء يصير لها لا تشيل هم يجون
هالبيت يقولون هل المستشفى كل الامور
ميسره الله يقويك ان شاء الله الله يحفظ
عليك الصحه والعافيه
الجوهره اشكرك جزيل الشكر لحضورك معنا
وشكرا ابو جمانه يكفي يعتقد ما عاد اقدر
ازيد شكرا
الرابعه وبالصحه ان شاء الله والعافيه
دائما همم عليكم
ضموا الينا في الاستديو هنا الجوهره
للطفله وولد الطفله نافع الحربي والطفل
ايضا جمانه شكرا لكم جميعا